- Oh, you can come this way.
Is it soft?
It looks soft.
- So soft!
- Yeah.
- I could sleep in it.
- I know, I'm not allowed to touch people,
but I really wanna touch your sweater.
- After we leave, I'll
take the sweater off.
I'll leave it here for a couple of days.
- Thank you, that's thoughtful.
- You touch, I'll come back, pick it up.
Sounds good.
- Touch your sweater sounds so creepy.
Put the lotion in the basket.
- Touch my sweater.
- It's awesome.
Wait, I mentioned "The Mindy Project."
So is it true that you used to
sneak into her dressing room?
'Cause there's a word for that.
- Yeah, yeah, I did.
You know, Mindy, I always said,
"Lock your doors,
when you're around me, lock your doors."
And a couple of times she forgot that.
So there were a few times
where I would sneak in
and I would put on her bra.
- Oh my God, please tell
me you took pictures?
- I took pictures of it.
I took pictures of it.
- And then you text her?
- 'Cause if you put on her bra
and you don't take pictures of it,
that's really creepy.
There we go, right there.
There you can see.
- [Kelly] Look at you, you're so free.
- I know I've never felt more-
- This is how we know you're not a woman,
you look happy in a bra.
(both laughing)
- That is true!
I don't know why you guys are complaining,
It felt great.
- That face is what happens
when you release them.
(Kelly laughing)
That's what happens there.
But I love that you'd sneak into her room
and take pictures.
- Can we just keep
that background up the whole time?
- Just the whole time.
- Is that okay?
- It's so great.
There's no segue for this,
you have three daughters?
- Yes.
- And one of them is friends
with Mindy's daughter.
So do they play together?
Y'all do play dates?
- Yeah, I mean,
it's been a little different
with COVID and everything,
but we do do play dates.
And when you go to Mindy's
house for a play date,
it's like the biggest
place that you've ever seen
and there's like games
and toys everywhere.
And then when kids come to my house,
it's like-
- We have a slip and slide!
- No, we have a hose.
Go hose off in the backyard.
- Where are the slip and slide?
They're very cheap.
- I think I have one Capri Sun around here
that you guys can all split.
You're gonna take a sip and then you,
and then you.
- So very good for COVID times.
- Very.
Well we have different straws.
- Pass the Capri Sun.
- So, you know how it works.
- I love that, I love that.
So wait, what's your favorite
thing to do with your kids?
- Well, they're already at the age of,
three girls where they
are very independent
and dad is already kind of not so cool.
- I'm not cool either to my seven year...
I embarrass her.
- Amongst my friends, my
grownup friends, I'm super cool.
My little daughters are
like, "You're a loser."
- Yeah.
- But there's, we love to read.
- And there's one book
that the eight year old,
the five-year-old and
three-year-old, all agree on.
It's a little book
called "River Rose and the Magic Lullaby."
- What?
Are you serious?
- Yes, I'm serious.
I've read this book many many times.
- I'm so sorry, I've read
the books the other ones,
they're like, you have to read
over and over and over again.
- Yeah.
But we will read it
and then the little one
just taps and goes, "Again."
So a lot of people come
here they love your music
and they love, and I love that too,
but I love "River Rose".
- Oh my God!
- And yes, thank you for clapping.
Thank you.
And I was wondering,
this is a little crazy.
I got a copy of it, our copy is very torn,
I bought a new copy at a bookstore.
- Okay, at a bookstore.
- At a bookstore.
- We support local businesses.
And I was wondering if you would sign it.
- I will, I totally will.
- Now I came to the studio last night
before anyone got here.
I slipped it under your chair.
- You really like breaking and entering.
- I do, I have a big problem.
So if you, it's under your chair.
Can you just stand up here?
- Oh yes.
- I thought this would be fun here.
Look at this.
Security guards, the
security guards chased me
for two hours last night.
Harry at the front chased me, he did.
So what I was thinking,
if I was able to come home
with a signed copy of this.
- They're gonna love you.
- Rockstar dad.
- Okay, okay, I got you.
- Look at this, thank you.
Thank you.
- I got you.
- This is how good dads are made.
- Okay, okay.
So wait, who do I make it out to?
So what are the, what are the names again?
- You know what?
Just make it out to Ike.
'Cause I'll tell you why,
'cause then they'll then,
then they're not gonna fight over it.
That way, it's in my name
and then it's dad's book and we all share.
- Not 'cause you're the fan?
Not 'cause yeah.
- Just say, "To Ike."
- Okay Ike, okay.
- "Follow your dreams."
This is my favorite.
- "You're a shining star."
- Okay, "Follow your dreams,
you are a shining star."
(Kelly laughing)
- And, "You have a lot of
friends and are super cool."
Last thing I'm asking.
- Star, smiley face.
- Then you have been just your name.
- Oh just my name, okay.
- You already wrote a book.
- Okay, you already wrote a book?
(Kelly laughing)
- Beautiful, look at that.
- I should put Ike and others.
- No, no, no, just Ike, thank you.
This one's for me, thank you.
- I love that, I love that.
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh.
So here's the funny thing
and you have, you have multiple children,
so you'll understand this.
It was a really cute
idea when I was pregnant
with my one child.
And now my son is like, "Where's my book?"
And I'm like, "It's, I'm
writing it like right now."
I'm actually writing it.
- It's called "River Rose
And The Frozen Pizza."
- "Remy B And His Adventures".
I literally think I'm gonna just make one
so I can give it to him
at Christmas or something.
'Cause he doesn't understand.
He feels like, yeah, like the last child,
like that just doesn't matter.
- "And my mum wrote a
book for the other kid.
I don't get one."
I don't get a New York times best seller.
- I know, I know.
I'm like, "I'll write you a song."
'Cause I also wrote a
song while I was pregnant
with my daughter that was on my album.
- You've gotta step it up.
- I've gotta step it up for Remy B.
What is "The Afterparty"
about and who do you play?
- "The Afterparty" is a
murder mystery on Apple TV,
but it's a comedy.
And the kind of, the
conceit is each episode
is told from the point of
view of one of the suspects
and each of their points of view
is in a certain movie genre.
So Sam Richardson, he's in
love with this girl, Zoe
and his kind of episode is like a rom-com.
My episode is, I'm kind of like
the cool guy in high school.
Who's now like a sad middle-aged guy.
- Like you peaked in high school?
- I peaked the high school,
it's happened before.
Not me.
- Not me.
I'm about to peak,
I feel like.
And his episode has kind of told
in the style of an action movie.
So each episode feels
like its own little movie,
but it kind of all tells the story
of this great who'd done it.
- That's brilliant.
- Really 'cause it's co-directed
by Chris Miller and Phil Lord
who did like the "Lego Movie".
- Yeah, so great.
- "21 Jump Street", so super fun.
If you like mysteries,
you're gonna love it.
But if you like comedy
was with funny people
doing stupid things,
you're also gonna be happy.
- Yeah, this is right up my alley.
- Right there.
- So I love too that it's so,
it's not only from
different vantage points,
it's different like takes on a movie.
That's so clever.
- Yeah, well the whole thing
is everyone in everyone's mind,
we're all the stars of our own movie.
And what genre is yours?
Are you a musical?
Are you film noir?
Are you like a greedy indie?
- I love that.
- So he kind of just fashioned
the whole show based on that.
- That's a brilliant concept.
Wait, so we were talking
about high school.
So in high school,
did you ever get caught doing
anything that you shouldn't?
I feel like you were maybe a prankster.
- I was a bit of a prankster,
bit of a prankster.
- Okay that's not shocking.
- I remember for our
prom one year I was like,
"Guys, I figured out a full-proof plan.
I'm gonna get the alcohol."
Right?
- Oh my God.
- So I placed this big
order at a liquor store
and I just used my grandfather's name.
'cause he had passed away.
He wasn't gonna use it.
- So he wasn't coming
to get any liquor, yeah.
- He was not gonna come to claim it.
He was passed away 10 years before that.
And so I went there and
I found someone to go in
and buy it for us.
And then like a month
later, my dad was like,
"Hey, I ran into my friend,
Fred who owns the liquor store.
And he said, my dad came in
and ordered a bunch of Zima,
(Kelly laughing)
which is funny because
my dad didn't like Zima
and he died in 1986."
So I got in a little bit
of trouble for that one.
- You live in too small of a town.
- Chicago?
- I know, but he or your family
frequents the liquor store.
- We're a shining light, a fog is lifting.
- I was like, wait, I was like-
- Like, "I went to the liquor
store again this morning and-"
- "I was saying hi to
everyone I know there."
- "I was just in the parking lot,
having a drink out of the bag."
- Even if you're from Chicago,
you all have your little like
weird little neighborhoods.
- We do, also Chicago is very provincial.
Like Chicago, people do
know each other in Chicago.
It's a huge city, but it is
weird, so you were right.
- See, it wasn't a weird thing to say Ike.
It's like, it's a Metropolis.
It's fine, I can't speak.
Okay wait, is it true that at one point
you wanted to become a politician?
- I did, I did.
'Cause I'm-
- I think you're too funny.
- You know it's, well
now I wouldn't want to,
but back then I remember I
would go on election day,
my dad was friends with politicians,
remember this is Chicago
so they're probably all in jail right now.
(Kelly laughing)
But I just remember on election day
being taken aback by how
many snacks there were,
there was donut holes and m&ms and-
- [Kelly] Craft service.
- Craft service.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was like, I wanna be in a business
where there is a little
designated snack area.
- [Kelly] You did that.
- And I did it.
- Yeah, you did that.
I made it.
- I just had some
bread crackers backstage, delicious.
- What of it.
No, I love it, it's so funny though.
I'm just like, usually
politicians are very serious
and don't have a sense of
humor or don't show it.
- Yes, that is true.
- So I was like,
you would be maybe a
politician I'd vote for.
- It's not too late.
- Maybe that's
what we're missing.
- And if you guys want me
to run for California Governor,
show me a round of applause right now.
(audience applauding)
- There's no one here.
- We'll pipe in the sound,
we'll sweeten the sound and post.
We'll sweeten and post.
- Oh my God, you're so funny.
There's no audience.
Okay, so if you were in for office,
would you be worried about what dirt?
Like would they come up?
Do you have dirt?
Do you have skeletons?
- I don't have a lot of dirt.
I was on mad TV for many years.
I have been in movies where I've been
in various states of undress.
I went through a bunch of
my photos and I was like,
I should just dump some of these,
just because they're not
even like scandalous per se.
- Okay.
- But I just don't know what they are.
And I was just like, I'll just dump them.
And I, do you guys want to, do you wanna-
- So you took the power?
You took the control.
- I took the power.
I'm not gonna let someone
hack into my photos
and leak these photos.
I want to present any of
them to you guys here today.
- See, you're owning it.
Okay.
- Guys, the band?
Can we get a little sting or something?
- Yeah, it's time for a photo
dump with Ike Barinholtz.
- Like a nice little kind
of like boom, boom, boom,
photo dump.
(drums beating)
(upbeat music)
I need a band.
- I need a band.
- I think you are in a band right now.
- That was amazing you guys.
- The Barinholtzers.
- [Ike] Oh my God.
- Okay, okay, wait, what's the first one?
Let's see.
- First one, what have we got?
What have we got here?
First photos dump, this is it.
I took a photo of the...
Oh, here we go.
Okay, so this is, this is our dog Pico.
- Okay.
- And my daughters, as we discussed,
they love the Disney
princesses, they love those.
So they gave him a princess makeover.
- [Kelly] Do you think Pico likes it?
- Pico hated it,
Pico hated it and just gave me a look.
You know, like I'm descended
from the North American gray wolf,
and here I am, you're making
a mockery of my lineage.
So, so I got rid of that one.
- They are.
Okay, wait, do you have another one?
- [Ike] I have another one.
Can we see the second one?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Ike] What is this?
Okay.
- [Kelly] Hey, I'm a fan.
- [Ike] I'm a fan too.
There's a photo of me
and a younger Harry Styles right there.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I have no memory of this photo.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I don't know where it was taken.
This might've been
coming out of a blackout,
but regardless I tell my kids
that I'm friends with Harry Styles.
- I love that.
I just saw his show, he was incredible.
- Ooh.
- I know he's in any
way, I was very excited.
Okay, one more.
- One more, what do we got here?
Oh, okay.
So this is this-
- [Kelly] I love this!
- This is my Bissell steam
cleaner and I took it-
- If you have children
or dogs, you need this.
- You need a steam cleaner
and the good folks at Bissell
make one that's top of the line folks.
Easy to use.
- Yes, I have it.
- Easy to clean.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Warranty available.
- Yeah sure, we just throw that out there.
- Just I don't know.
- We just say things.
- I just say things, but
before I started cleaning,
I noticed that that really looks
like one of the helmets to Daft Punk.
(Kelly laughing)
And so I spent a while
taking a photo shoot of it,
and various things and then-
- Oh my God.
- It kind of does,
you could do that in a
French rave somewhere.
- Yes.
- But I figured I should
lose it from my photo roll
just in case, so I'm clean now.
I'm able to run for office.
- And you're also helping people out
because that will get a
stain out, is all I'm saying.
- It's not just like you spilled coffee,
this is paint, this is-
- Dog vomit.
- Yeah.
- Human vomit.
It doesn't matter.
(Kelly clapping and laughing)
The folks at Bissell are gonna make-
- They're gonna take care of you.
- That rug look good as new folks.
- We should be a sponsor.
- We should, are they not already?
What are we doing here?
Leaving money on the table.